las tortas de trigo son un pilar en la
dieta egipcia y se han convertido en un
indicador de la crisis alimentaria su
precio ha aumentado un 25% desde que
empezó la invasión rusa a ucrania egipto
es el principal importador de trigo en
el mundo y el año pasado el 70% de sus
cereales provinieron de rusia y de
ucrania
y
este trigo se utiliza para el pan
subvencionado del que se benefician 80
millones de egipcios inscritos en
programas de ayudas públicas y su
función
que no podrían acceder a este alimento
si no encontramos otra forma importar
trigo hondo tuco amor y el del portillo
de rusia y ucrania producen un tercio
del volumen de las exportaciones
mundiales de cereales pero ucrania no
puede exportar debido al bloqueo de sus
puertos y la cosecha de este año es
incierta por otro lado se presume que
las sanciones impuestas contra rusia
perturben aún más las exportaciones pero
egipto no es el único país que verá
perjudicada sus reservas de cereales por
la guerra kazajistán mongolia líbano y
turquía también dependen en más de un
70% de rusia y ucrania en términos de
importaciones de este alimento en áfrica
sub-sahariana somalia benin madagascar y
república democrática del congo también
temen el impacto de la escasez las
consecuencias se prevén todavía peores
en sudán de más del 85 por ciento del
trigo procede de rusia y ucrania por lo
que casi la mitad de la población
sudanesa podría verse afectada por la
hambruna este año de aquí a final de año
alrededor de 20 millones de personas la
mitad de la población estará en
situación de inseguridad alimentaria
una inseguridad alimentaria que va de
mano de la inflación debilitados por la
crisis sanitaria y la inestabilidad
regional la economía de varios países
africanos podría empeorar maquis al
presidente de senegal y de la unión
africana pidió este martes el apoyo del
banco mundial y de socios
internacionales para afrontar las
consecuencias de la guerra en ucrania